promise me we do this together okay I
promise
Elsa was a wonderful Queen but honor
it's you who was born to rule over
arendelle you're a natural leader and
your people respect you you don't need
to have powers to save the day and
you've proven that to everyone time and
time again I also wanted to go on her
journey alone but if it hadn't been for
you she still be in El sickle in the
river full of memory frozen fans are so
fond of the sequel that they've made it
a point to watch it over and over again
but the more they watch frozen too the
more they realize that it's jam-packed
with inconsistencies watch until the end
to find out which major plot hole Agner
and I do his marriage left behind if
you're watching on your mobile go on
YouTube settings internal notifications
Elsa Anna and the entire gang spend the
whole day traveling to the enchanted
forest from arendelle but for some
strange reason nobody in arendelle seems
to know about the forest or the fog
barrier that surrounds it Elsa and Anna
didn't know about the Natalia tribe or
the mysterious fog until Elsa woke up
the spirits and was called north but
surely this phenomenon would have been
the talk of the town for many decades
yet somehow the Queen and the princess
of arendelle were never led in on the
secret this could have made sense if
arendelle and Dean chantin forests were
very far apart but soon as they're
literally under a day walk away from
each other
fanta viewing this as a major plot hole
the last thing Elsa wanted was to put
her little sister in danger so she sends
her away in an ice canoe and never
looked back I also went on to tame the
wild nock and cross the dark seat Santa
Hollen where she eventually froze solid
in the river full of memory but before
she passed away she found out the truth
about her grandfather's betrayal and
sent the memory to Anna this way Anna
would be able to take down to them and
bring down the barrier but when you
think about it this thing doesn't really
make sense
Elsa froze solid before the message
could reach Anna so her message should
never have made it to honor pants also
since when do Elsa's powers have a
built-in GPS tracker they were able to
locate Anna in an underground cave
Elsa's final message was crucial to the
plot but some viewers are choosing to
see it as an inconsistency honor is
super brave and smart which is what
helped her defeat Hans and frozen one
and right her grandfather's wrongs and
frozen too but fans couldn't help but
gasp when Anna was ready to sacrifice
arendelle to undo the past everyone in
arendelle was safe and sound in the
mountains with the trolls Gale made sure
of that that everything they knew and
loved was in arendelle and Anna was
ready to destroy it to make the spirits
of the forest happy again Anna didn't
hesitate before waking up the earth
Giants and running towards the dam she
knew it was the only way to bring the
fog barrier down she was ready to
sacrifice her people's homes livelihoods
and possessions and if it hadn't been
for Elsa she would have done just that
honest people would not have been happy
with her if that had been the outcome if
arendelle had fallen honor would never
have become Queen I also gave her life
to find out the truth she made sure that
honor had
all the information she needed to bring
down the dam and make the spirits happy
again Elsa must have realized what
bringing down the dam truly meant
because the second she was defrosted she
rushed to arendelle to stop the huge way
from swallowing the kingdom whole but
here's the problem
Elsa only began to unfreeze when the dam
was destroyed yet Elsa somehow made it
to arendelle in time to save it
how did Elsa managed to get out of on to
Holland and across the dark sea all the
way to arendelle in the nick of time it
just doesn't add up
but hey arendelle is still standing so
we're not complaining here are the
things we post new Disney theories every
single week
so make sure to subscribe to the things
to stay in the loop and don't forget to
click that Bell turn on those post
notifications King Agner loves his
daughters and would do anything to
protect them but when Elsa's powers
nearly cost him Anna he taught her to
conceal don't feel and frozen to we find
out that Agner knowingly married in the
cauldron despite what happened in the
forest a lot of fans don't understand
why Agner and I do now kept Elsa's
powers hidden for so long after all it
wasn't like powers were unheard of a
magical forest was located just one day
away from arendelle and tons of people
knew about it so what was up with all
the secrecy it seriously messed with
Elsa's head and that's a wrap on the
five major inconsistencies and potholes
and frozen - who was your favorite new
character from the sequel tell us in the
comments
unicorn ice-cream castle okay thanks for
watching don't forget to give this video
a big thumbs up we'll see you next time
on the thing
[Music]